continental tire coaches corner brought
to you by cutting little tire you'll see
Continental Tire at sporting venues
across the United States proud sponsor
the EMSA racing Major League Soccer and
force college basketball Continentals
premium products available at leading
independent tire dealers car dealers
mass retailer companies across the
United States for more information visit
continental tire calm continental tire
for what you do with the victory over
washington USC is now won six in a row
he's the head coach of the Trojans clay
Helton joining us how do you feel today
coach feeling good Dan thank you for
having me uh when did you look at the
game film uh when I got home I actually
watched a little bit of it on the plane
coming back and then came immediately
home and watched the TV copy till about
4am that morning and adrenaline was
running and get back up and get ready
for now rivalry game with UCLA so no
rest for the weary got it got to keep
going have you ever not watched game
film just because you just knew it
probably wasn't going to lead to
anything good now that's usually not in
a coach's DNA whether it's good or bad
you're going to learn from the mistakes
or pick up some lessons learned on every
tape so that's just part of being a
coach your pregame speech guy yeah yeah
I am I appreciate given the message and
making sure that the team understands
exactly what we're trying to get
accomplished so I'm I am us pregame
speech guy what did you say prior to
Washington I'm just do the same things
do the simple things better just like
we've been doing over the last six weeks
and don't change anything because of the
atmosphere that we were in we we learned
a lot of lessons over the first ten
weeks starting at the alabama game and
being in that type atmosphere and in the
lessons that we learned there will help
pay off for today and it did I thought
the kids did a tremendous job of
drowning out all the distractions in a
very unique in hostile environment and
play their butts off I thought the
difference the difference has been the
defense I've watched the offense I think
I've watched probably five tote full
games the last five
and the offense is spectacular it really
is there's so many weapons and I kept
wondering can you play any defense and
then you guys I thought the defense won
that game for you they were they were
great y-yeah I every day I go to bed I
thank God for three things my wife my
children and claims he pendergast
because that coordinator is is it in
that order no clay sometimes yeah but no
Clancy's done an unbelievable job with
our defense and really our defensive
front has led the way you know we played
back to back games now against the two
highest ranked rushing teams in our
conference in Oregon and Washington and
Clancy's always found a way to do a
terrific job of taking away a team
strength and then our defensive front
over the last six teams the big men have
led the way and and have really gotten
to the quarterback got to a really good
quarterback in Jake this past week and
and eliminated a run game that was elite
and then you put that secondary back
there I did a great job edori comes up
with two picks in Game one to end the
game so just a great effort by our kids
when did you know that Sam Darnell could
actually play it this kind of level um
in high school you know being a
quarterback coach by trade and to have
an opportunity to go watch him you know
I'll never forget the time you hit one
evaluation in a fall to go out and see a
kid and you go out and watch him and
there's you know USC coaches on the
sideline and and you think a kid would
be nervous and he goes out there in the
first half and he goes 13 of 13 with
five touchdown passes and I was like yep
that's that could be a really good one
and then he comes here and just the
poise that he's shown since a day he
stepped on campus and the leadership you
knew that at some point in time great
things were going to happen to the kid
he's just he's just one of those guys
that has it I mean he's a winner but
you're not sure how it translates to
colleges like a college player to the
NFL and you don't know that until you
get him into game action and and that's
what's impressed me is he's he's
athletic he's got a quick release and it
looks like he's just not afraid I mean
he's smart but not afraid I and that's a
registered redshirt freshman doing that
and you did that on the road at u-dub I
thought that was real
really impressive and I think he's legit
I think he's a legitimate star in the
making there yeah he's done a terrific
job his game maturity for this age is
beyond his years I mean just the way
he's distributing the ball to several
kids you know protecting the football
creating creating not only with his legs
but really looking downfield as he
creates and has come up with several
touchdown passes off you know breaking
contained in finding guys downfield so
he's got a really bright future and the
thing that i apprec-- about him is his
humbleness and who is humility every
game he comes off the field and says you
know what coach I can do better I'm
learning from from my mistakes I'll do
better next time you appreciate that as
a coach he's clay Helton UNC head coach
they got UCLA coming up next game but
when you after that Alabama again hmm
like if you juxtapose the feeling you
have now after beating Washington as
opposed to how you felt after that
alabama game the highs and the lows how
low were you after alabama um pretty low
me you know you you have great
anticipation of a team that you know is
talented and you know you've got three
new coordinators and you've got five new
position coaches a new head coach for
the first time and you know we really
needed to come together as a team and we
were quite ready and we had some lessons
that we learned in those first four
games and we just I tell you I really
appreciate our staff and our kids for
just every week trying to get better and
I looked at us from going from Alabama
to Stanford Stanford do Utah and I
really felt like we were improving each
week even though we were one and three
and the staff and the kids just kept on
grinding kept on getting better with
each game focusing on our jobs and you
look up and you hope you're playing your
best football in November and that's
what we're doing right now coolest thing
that you have in your office is what
coolest thing I have in the office a
picture with me and my mom and dad after
Latin last year's Colorado game and just
just I'd look at it every day because my
dad is my hero in my mentor and I'm the
lessons that he's taught me is has put
me in a position to be able to handle
that versity and so I look at that often
each and every day when you're one in
three and all of a sudden you
here in whispers and they're not
whispers anymore who processes that and
how does it not affect you when you um
you know I've learned that I've learned
that after being in it for 21 years the
job is too hard to focus on any noise
that's going around you and especially
when you're in a leadership position
whether you're one and three or whether
you're undefeated kids look to 18 to 21
year olds look to you to see how you're
going to react and if you show panic if
you if you show that hey you know I'm
not confident you need to go into that
position saying hey guys we're not
changing what we're doing we're going to
get better with each and every game and
we're going to look up and we'll add
them all up in the end because they look
to you every day for leadership and
guidance so I just tried to stay the
same each and every week and be the
leader that they needed and in credit to
the kids they've done a terrific job
well congrats it's quite a turnaround
their 15th in the country seven and
three and good luck against UCLA clay
then preciate it so much right clay help
yeah you're one in three and all of a
sudden you know they're they're starting
to take a look at custer here with his
last stand there firing arrows at him
and people are looking like oh who would
take over that job you know Brian Kelly
if he went in there and went they played
four games and now they're ready to get
rid of another coach I don't think
that's going to happen maybe at the end
of the year if it all goes bad but not
after one and three but watching that
alabama game that's where you looked at
it you went there's a big difference
between Alabama and USC but I love to
I'd love to see them play now it'd be a
completely different game Alabama still
a better team but USC that offense they
got a couple running backs they got good
receivers and I'm telling you watching
fall flat on his face against UCLA Sam
dartle can play he's really good and he
was the best quarterback on the field
Saturday night coach Helton brought to
you by Continental Tire Coaches Corner
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience